on va prendre le premier patient guéri
du coronavirus à s'exprimer en france
c'est josue il est menuisier de 31 ans
qui habite près de mulhouse
s'il va pouvoir retrouver une vie
normale après quatorze jours de
confinement
lui sa femme et ses deux filles
katherine est de 6 ans ont été
diagnostiqués positifs au coronavirus
c'est la première fois qu'un patient
guéri va s'exprimer à la télévision
voilà c'est il a été contaminé lors d'un
événement religieux organisé par
l'église évangélique la porte ouverte
il est l'un des fils du pasteur mike
juste avant qu'on les eaux par skype est
ce que vous avez peur du coronavirus
envie d'avoir la vie d'un aventurier
voilà je pense pas vraiment je pense que
aujourd'hui on doit ré on doit ré
d'avoir peur de tout et puis aussi quand
on a peur on se cache et puis en fait
confronté un peu la réalité c'est aussi
une manière de vaincre la réalité mais
pis moi qui ai souvent qui visent
souvent près la mort j'ai pas peur de
sortir de la tente et d'essayer de
rester vivant et puis je pense que des
fois un content quand on se cache on
devient prespective heures de notre vie
on ne vit pas mais il ya des raisons
quand même d'être inquiet parce que
c'est l'équipe pas il ya les raisons
allait concerner des raisons mais il
faut affronter voit quoi il faut il faut
réfléchir à quelles quel impact ça doit
avoir sur ta vie d'accord je pense que
c'est personnel aussi alors on va voir
je suis au téléphone il a 31 ans
est-ce que je suis est ce qu on salue je
suis enfin bonjour à tous merci d'être
là je suis à ce qu'on peut avoir plus de
retour en plateau les chéris souplet
merci d'être avec nous merci de nous
donner cette première interview alors
vous êtes menuisier josue vous avez
attrapé le coronavirus entre le 17 et le
23 février c'est ça oui c'est exactement
ça durant notre semaine de jeunes à
l'église c'est là bas que j'ai dû être
contaminés et dans la foulée on a fêté
mon anniversaire le lundi
avec toute ma famille et je pense que là
on se lève vraiment partagé à toute ma
famille qui est finalement aujourd'hui
toute ma famille est positive
coronavirus vos deux filles votre votre
épouse c'est ça une 8 mai deux enfants
alors j'ai deux filles de quatre ans et
demi et une de 6 ans et mon épouse on a
tous été diagnostiqué positif donc
coronavirus alors comment comment vous
avez su vous aviez le coronavirus
comment ça s'est tout de suite quand
vous vous êtes senti mal c'est quoi les
symptômes alors ce qui s'est passé pour
moi c'est que suite à cette semaine deux
jeunes j'étais très fatigué alors pour
moi aucun doute ça venait de cette
semaine puisque j'avais pas mangé
pendant une semaine
donc automatiquement j'étais fatigué de
là mais au bout de trois jours j'ai
vraiment eu des symptômes de grippe
là j'ai été mis en arrêt maladie puis
par la suite on a appris qu'ils avaient
a eu un cas de coronavirus donc dans
notre communauté
à ce moment là on a tout de suite pris
les devants et on a fait le test qui une
semaine plus tard donc je lai a pris une
fois que mes symptômes commencé à s'en
aller a été avéré positif
ceci dit les symptômes c'était vraiment
pour moi alors c'était très mal au
dessus des yeux des grosses courbatures
j'ai eu beaucoup de fièvre des vertiges
pas mal de vertige donc du jeudi au
lundi j'ai été vraiment alité et c'est
alors c'est mon cas dans ma famille on
est 18 personnes à avoir été positive
mais j'ai envie de dire que les 18 ont
vécu la chose différemment et ils sont
pratiquement tous guéri notre famille
d'odile et 18 où il y en a encore qui
sont malades
alors aujourd'hui je dirais que la
majorité ma famille va très bien on a
une personne qui est tout de même
hospitalisé c'est vraiment pour ces
personnes qu'on pense aujourd'hui
j'aimerais reçu à redon c'est une
personne plus âgée
voilà enfin plus âgée elle a 50 ans donc
la porte à ces très aléatoire maintenant
c'est important pour moi de dire aux
gens qu'ils auraient besoin peut-être
d'être rassurés au niveau des enfants
voilà tous les enfants de notre famille
ont été contaminées
aujourd'hui quasiment la majorité n'ont
pas eu de symptômes et ils vont très
très bien donc voilà je sais qu'il y en
aura qui auront des symptômes plus
graves mais la majorité des enfants dans
notre entourage font très très bien et
n'ont pas eu de symptômes
alors je suis parce que c'est vrai qu'il
ya plein de gens qui se disent
aujourd'hui c'est la petite ou non dit
est ce qu'on a le cou raide un virus est
ce qu on n'a pas dès qu'on a un petit
peu malade et dès qu'on a un petit peu
des courbatures aux hirondelles
coronavirus vous donc vous dites pour
vos enfants pour votre femme ça c'était
les mêmes symptômes que vous y avez mal
au dessus des yeux il avait des vertiges
ou bien ils avaient des symptômes
différents
alors il m'a emmené mes enfants n'ont
même pas eu de symptômes
ah ouais ma femme a eu elle s'est sentie
fatiguée elle a eu delà de la fière mon
grand frère lui a eu plutôt un rhume
enfin voila c'est vraiment aléatoire par
contre il n'ya qu'une personne de notre
entourage qui a eu les problèmes
respiratoires qui sont différents de la
grippe d'accord alors dont vous avez été
dépistés le 3 mars
vous êtes allé à l'hôpital de mulhouse
vous avez été pris en charge dans une
salle à part dédiée au corona virus et
donc il ya vous amis donc un coton tige
dans le nez c'est ça oui
et encore on a envoyé sa au labo et les
résultats sont tombés le lendemain soir
à 23h vous avez paniqué quand on vous a
dit que vous avez le corps d'un virus
excusez moi juste là vous à la question
vous avez panique et josue quand on vous
a dit que vous étiez positif que vous
aviez le coronavirus alors si j'ai bien
compris est ce que j'ai paniqué on va
pas du tout vraiment pas avec cent soit
j'étais sur la fin de mes symptômes
mes enfants étaient aussi positif il
avait aucun symptôme et la majorité de
mon entourage qui a été diagnostiquée
positive n'avaient pas de symptômes et
donc on n'a vraiment pas été paniqués
dans ce sens là d'accord vous alors vous
allez reprendre une vie normale puisque
vous retourner au travail et demain
c'est ce que vous avez dit voilà alors
pour ma part à partir de demain je
retourne au travail insectes aux mes
collègues
donc je vais retrouver une vie normale
hui et nan j'ai envie de dire parce que
ce qui est important de dire c'est que
aujourd'hui je peux me considérer guéri
étant donné que les médecins ont
finalement mon
vous restez 400 jours confinés à la fin
il ya plus de symptômes vous pouvez vous
considérez guerrien donc ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est que je garde quand
même une certaine précaution par
sécurité et par respect aussi de ce qui
m'entoure je comprends tout à fait que
mes collègues et pas forcément envie de
me sauter dans les bras de nos matins
c'est seulement par rapport à mes
grands-parents quoi voilà vous avez vous
allez voir vos grands parents vous avez
été les voir tout ça vous avez peur
d'aller les voir les personnes plus
âgées
alors voilà pour ce qui est de mes
grands parents au sein de ma famille on
a vraiment décidé de mettre un protocole
en place c'est ok on a le droit de
sortir ma par contre on évite d'aller
les voir on les a au téléphone où on
prend des précautions si vraiment il
faut aller les aider
donc on met un masque on se protège les
mains on prend le maximum de précaution
même si on est donnée guéri aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment important pour nous
finalement de prendre soin des personnes
qui sont aujourd'hui fragiles ou avec
des symptômes très graves
juste je suis vous nous dites que vous
êtes vous avez été guéri vous avez vu
donc des médecins ils vous ont donné
quoi comme comme médicament pour vous
guérir comment vous avez guéri en fait
ou bien si avec le temps vous sait pas
c'est que le temps mais avec vous ont
donné des médicaments spécifiques
alors moi comme j'ai été vraiment dans
les moments difficiles je savais même
pas que j'avais le coronavirus donc je
me traitaient pour une grippe c'était
paracétamol sirops contre la toux et
vitamines
donc ce qui s'est passé c'est que j'ai
simplement continué avec ça et c'est le
temps aussi le repos qui a refait que
les symptômes sont petit à petit se sont
emballés je suis vous vous sentiez plus
malade plus atteints que quand vous
aviez une simple grippe où c'est moins
moins violent qu'une grosse grippe le
coronavirus alors il est clair que pour
mon témoignage personnel si j'avais pas
été de diane diagnostiqués pour le
coronavirus j'aurai une grippe comme
j'ai jamais ça c'est sûr donc en en
quatre à cinq jours
quand j'étais vraiment très très mal
j'étais allongé dans mon lit quoi
d'accord donc c'est une très très grosse
grippe porcine grippe comme vous n'avez
jamais eu c'est une au dessus des autres
ça a été pour les autres personnes de
votre famille vous nous aviez dit
qu'elle avait 18 cas toutes ont été
très fatiguée où il y en a on n'a même
pas su qu'elle avait le court mandat
virus est passé comme ça et puis on voit
là on les moindres pas ressenti à part
les enfants parce que vous avez dit que
les enfants ne l'aï pas ressentie mais
votre femme par exemple où les autres
membres de votre famille alors pour les
autres cas de ma famille ça a été comme
moi exactement les mêmes traitements je
dirais qu'une grippe
sauf on a un cas qui a quand même dû
être hospitalisés qui a dû voilà avoir
un suivi médical plus poussée et c'est
ça qui est important c'est que vraiment
si on a des symptômes légers faut pas
qu'on rentre dans une panique et qu'on
puisse laisser les hôpitaux et et toutes
les personnes compétentes les médecins
qui puisse vraiment être à disposition
pour les personnes qui sont dans des
états beaucoup plus grave que nous merci
en tout cas je suis vous souhaite un bon
rétablissement à votre famille aussi
bien d'où est bon et bonne reprise du
travail demain c'est un menuisier on
embrasse tous les menus et d'ailleurs
qui font travailler si je suis fan des
minutes et je trouve que c'est un métier
exceptionnel merci je suis d'avoir été
avec lui merci beaucoup merci
[Applaudissements]